all of our players at home they want to
see
one of the new maps that we've never
talked about before
really i can just like i can just talk
about
anything that i want to yeah you're
serving this up to the guy that is like
unintentionally leaked information and
past
interviews you can do it officially now
okay so one of the maps that i'm
i'm most excited for in overwatch 2
is our rome map
we always want overwatch to feel like
this globetrotting adventure for our
players
so we're having a lot of fun coming up
with the overwatch version of rome
we wanted a very romantic sort of this
powerful feeling of old world
architecture
one of the most exciting things for me
is the early building of these maps
where we get to sit down together with
key people from the environment team
level designers
effects groups we'll spend some time
talking about moments in the game that
we really want to see
like the colosseum or a grand view of
the hills of rome in the backdrop and
then we'll go back and do
a paint over or we'll do a concept
painting of certain things based on that
we try to draw inspiration from as many
different sources as possible for
example
one of our environment artists had just
taken a trip to rome
and he returned with thousands of
pictures and was
so excited um to work on a map
set in italy there's a lot of ancient
architecture in rome that
represents the empire that it used to be
so
we brought some of that back some of the
things that are destroyed in real life
we kind of rebuilt in a kind of
overwatch style
it's one of the most beautiful pieces of
environment art that i think we've made
for the entire game and it just
absolutely took my breath away
can we reveal more maps yes scott
scott why don't you have the honor why
don't you reveal
like is there an artifice like let's
pick an artified one
i know what map i want to talk about
it's the one that i just get super
excited about
new york city new york city is
just an amazing overwatch location
we're really striving to make it as
authentic as possible while still
putting this overwatch spin on it
there's a lot of amazing buildings and
architecture pieces that just especially
for artists stands out a lot
and they usually use this kind of art
deco style from the 1920s 1950s
we started in an area that's a little
bit like the village
there's some smaller shops there there's
a fire station
little pizza places and things that
people that are familiar
with new york city will either recognize
or maybe
see the reference that we're trying to
make with some of our different
locations
it feels like something you haven't seen
in other games before because it's
uniquely
overwatch
[Music]